hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
injustice to has just arrived and to be
fully prepared for the campaign we're
taking a look back everything that
happened in the injustice gods among us
story I'll try my best to get all three
hours of the campaign into about 10
minutes ish if I ever run I apologize
let's do this oh and be prepared for me
to say alternative about a hundred times
sorry about that injustice gods among us
that in an alternative universe with a
captured Joker being interrogated by
Batman you following an explosion which
has leveled metropolis and killed
millions of innocent people the
preceding moments are in the comic books
so let's fill in that blank now Lois
Lane and her unborn child are being
operated upon by the Joker who sets the
bomb to explode when her heart stops
beating in comes Superman to save Lois
and the super baby of course but he
ingests some sort of hallucinogenic and
believes Lois is doomsday easy mistake
to make I know Batman tries to make
Superman see sense but it's too late and
Superman has killed Lois and his baby
which takes us back to the video game
Superman bursts into the interrogation
room he's devastated
he's unhinged and the Joker can't help
but fuel that anger again
it cost a black before it happens but
Superman punches a hole straight through
the Joker killing him once and for all
he ago you see really see it for
yourself we now switch to another
universe which we're going to call the
real universe please believe me that
will be quite important later on anyway
in this universe Lois is alive Superman
is still a likable chap and the bomb
isn't in Joker's possessions yet we pick
up with the Justice League fighting Lex
Luthor and his cronies as he breaks the
Joker out of prison it doesn't take long
for the Justice League to muffle this
crop of super villains and the captured
Lex tells us our next story point but I
can see the headlines Justice League
fails clown kills millions
you gave him a nuke most of the league
dies and Superman's beloved city is
vaporized as Batman reaches the Joker
he's one button press away from wiping
out metropolis but just as he presses
the trigger Batman the Joker
Aquaman Green Arrow Green Lantern and
Wonder Woman are all transported into
that alternate universe we saw at the
start yeah the one where metropolis was
blown up and Superman was a little vexed
when they arrived it's five years later
and in this alternative universe
Superman is a bit of a bastard he is now
a tyrant who rules with an iron fist and
murders anyone who disagreed with him
this means all the heroes we know and
love
could be working for Superman in this
alternative universe so keep that in
mind anyway back to the story
Superman's military are quick to arrest
the Caped Crusader and the Joker but
Bruce gates because well Batman in
linkster the remaining members of the
Justice League try to figure out how
they have jumped to another dimension
and of course they separate because
that's always a good thing to do isn't
it first up Green Lantern looks to
recharge his ring at an airfield but
stumbles across the alternate versions
of Raven and cyborg who are torturing
Deathstroke how steps in and frees
Deathstroke but he makes a run for it
don't worry he'll be back soon enough
them meanwhile aqua
travels to Atlantis to search for
answers and discovers his alternate self
is about to give rule of Atlantis over
to Superman
meaning all his underwater armies would
be forced to support the tyrannical
superhero he doesn't stand for that and
beat the [ __ ] out of himself before
meeting back up with the team who have
found the alternate Batman
he doesn't like Superman and he has an
unexpected backer too unlike your Luthor
I've never indulged in law breaking
Superman doesn't suspect his best friend
is funding the insurgency alternative
Lex Luthor is a good guy who's
Superman's best friend too just just
take a second to get your head round
that one Lex Luthor is a good guy
alternate Batman revealed he has a
kryptonite based weapon which will
incapacitate Superman even in his
Batcave but it can only be opened by
five members of the Justice League this
is the main reason why they suddenly
jumped from one universe into another
and it also explains that Batman and the
Joker were supposed to be pulled through
with them a few little potential story
threads which could be uncovered further
in injustice two are revealed such as
what looks to be the start of a
relationship between Wonder Woman and
Superman are you okay with this with us
of course I'm not trying to replace her
I just thought we I know but the memory
of Lois seems to be curtailing that
whilst all of this is going on the Joker
has once again escaped from prison and
bumped into Batman
this time the Joker gets the upper hand
and Batman is detained by alternative
Hawkgirl and the yellow lantern and me
without my camera that could have gotten
10 million years
the talkative bumps into alternative
Harlequin who doesn't believe he's a
joker you know this wouldn't remember he
tries to convince her Harley it's me I'm
the Joker look it's it's all right here
on my underwear
not funny creep what's the only way the
Joker can convince Harley is by beating
the crap out of her because that's how
domestic violence works I presume Cuba
the way you move
it's the love you could feel the love
right Harley takes the Joker to her
hideout where he gives a rousing speech
to his new henchmen he now somehow has a
supply of super pills that will make him
and his cronies indestructible but
before he can continue in verse
alternate Nightwing and Hawkgirl
bringing along Superman's military force
who opened fire on the Joker we did
thanks happy milk a few moments later
the good guys arrive and the bodies make
a run for it alternate carla is in
cahoots with alternate Batman so the
Joker is put in jail for safety reasons
of course more of them will be here soon
go I'll catch up with you hula alternate
Superman which others call an evil super
month anyway I'm getting sidetracked
Superman goes to visit the incarcerated
Batman and instantly knows he is not the
Batman for this universe nice workout
how did you got him what back at Wayne
Manor
our heroes make their way to the Batcave
interrupted with a few fights of course
and some really cool minigames like the
stolen Grundy ones anyway here they
unlock the weapon that will defeat the
tyrant Superman remember Deathstroke
from earlier well he locates alternate
Lex and joins his resistance and
effectively becomes the hero we all knew
he was back in the real universe good
Superman cyborg and the flash are trying
to locate their missing heroes they come
up with a plan to use the Flash's speed
on the cosmic treadmill to open a portal
and drag back Batman the Joker
Aquaman Green Arrow Green Lantern and
Wonder Woman the story dips in analysis
but when the machine is functioning it
kind of works in the wrong direction and
cyborg is flung into the alternate
universe accidentally here he notices
Lex and Deathstroke speaking about
killing Superman and doesn't realize
that this universe is backwards and
decides to beat the [ __ ] out of them
that's all I needed to hear
Eddie's cyborg Batman
welcome to Oz Tin Man in an attempt to
learn up our heroes alternate Superman
declares he will execute Batman on live
TV
he's even nice enough to say when and
where leader of the insurgency will pay
for his crimes oh I don't like this at
6:00 p.m. local time
Batman will be executed at Strykers
Island
we're--aw ever see on his song
cyborg and Deathstroke go to the
watchtower Space Station to create a
teleportation system to be used to save
Batman before he's executed whilst doing
this cyborg is forced to take down
Catwoman after she figures out he's an
imposter and then he has a pretty cool
face-to-face with alternate cyborg and
the to attempt to hack each of the
systems before deciding to fight like
men
I mean robot no men got cyborgs for
fight like cyborgs Deathstroke goes AWOL
and sets off a core reaction meaning the
space station will explode in 90 minutes
all because he was tortured earlier on
in the story
geez talk about holding a grudge it's
almost time for Batman to be executed so
Superman self Strykers Island with his
military forces
[Music]
the first man to make a move is Aquaman
who has brought some sort of shellfish
to fight
come on Aquaman you have an entire ocean
full of awesome creatures and you choose
bloody crayfish talk about damp squib or
rather a dub squid filled that the
coveted you convolve fool anyway ask
Batman and Green Arrow fights through
the compounds they come up again from
Nightwing and this bit has a few people
confused this is Damian Wayne Wayne his
son but Superman's been more of a father
than you ever were you stopped being my
son when you kill Dick Grayson he was my
son
waha I saw I checked what happened and
yet in the comics a disgruntled Damian
Wayne threw his baton thing at Dick's
head as a joke in there somewhere and in
this case it's hid him he fell awkwardly
and popped his clogs there and then
Batman never forgave his son and
Superman pretty much became a father
figure to him you're dead to me whilst
the war continues outside alternate
Batman finds our Batman and slowly gets
him outside the building so he can be
teleported by cyborg of course it isn't
that easy and tyrant Superman quickly
intercepts them I perfected this world
so many lives lost because I held back
when I should have used all my power for
what to control to a press in the nick
of time
cyborg transports both Batman and the
Green Arrow but there's only one place
that this can be done from Watchtower
Superman flies up to the watchtower
Space Station but if you remember
rightly Deathstroke set off a Corps
reaction so just as Superman arrives the
space station goes
don't worry about anybody on board they
all got off safely
meanwhile the alternate Lex Luthor yes
that's the good version of him is about
to fly into space and fight Superman
one-on-one but just as he takes off he
is shot out of the sky by the Joker and
Harley Quinn because Holly couldn't
resist his charm and freed him from
prison after Lex defeat Ollie the Joker
being the unhinged individual you know
and love decides Allie is no longer
required I've got this I don't think
I'll ever get used to this Lex Luthor
Superman rushes back down to earth to
confront Lex and just as Lex is about to
shoot Superman with the Kryptonite
weapon this happens
bloody Shazam electrocutes the bald
bugger
don't worry too much about us now he'll
get what's coming to him very soon your
Superman isn't playing around anymore
and murdered Lex he then goes funny but
it crazy and vows to flatten Gotham and
then invade the alternate universes
Shazam attempts to talk some sense into
Superman but he politely refuses seeing
his friend killed prompts alternate
flash to switch sides and he runs to
their aid but first he removes a few
weapons from Superman soldier's keeping
mind the battle is still raging on at
this point on Strykers Island in the air
and even the Amazons are involved to the
to Batman's the to Batman's the Batman's
the Batman the to Batman's managed to
pull the crew Superman into the
alternate universe and he's ready to
stop taking down black atoms the yellow
lantern and doomsday
which all leads to the final showdown
the real lovable Superman's against
these evil alternative Superman rejected
that's what's happening out there
protection disobedient children will be
punished children not gods we don't
decide who lives and who dies as your
gears mine it became mine when Joker
turned me into a weapon of mass
destruction I know what you lost and you
judge me as if the fight was ever in
doubt good Superman wipe the floor with
alternate Superman but he's doesn't kill
him instead Batman and Superman placed
him in a red kryptonite cell taking away
his powers and leaving him to sit and
think about all the bad things he's done
to tie up a few loose ends the flashes
which sides is arrested the Joker is
arrested well pretty much all
accomplices to the evil Superman have
been arrested at this point Lex Luthor
gets his own Monument and Batman reminds
the good Superman what will happen if he
ever crosses the line if something ever
happens and you do lose it I come
we'll have to get online it looks like
everything is rectified doesn't it and
we have a nice little ending to enjoy
but wait the final shot shows the evil
Superman seemingly powerless in itself
but look
[Music]
his glowing eyes show us he still has
his powers and probably the anger issues
to who so that was a whistle-stop tour
of the first injustice game in about 10
minutes
ish you are now ready to play in justice
to give it a few weeks and I'll have a
breakdown of that story too if I've
missed anything please shout it out in
the comments I'm Adam from Playstation
grenade I'll see you next time